China is bouncing back from the effects
of coronavirus and the world is watching
to see what they can expect from life
after lockdown China's economy is now
functioning it's around 90 percent of
normal levels 90 percent is an
incredible achievement but in practice
will feel very very strange a 90 percent
economy may not sound too bad but for
many it could be catastrophic some of
the worst unemployment numbers in this
country's history 6.6 million plus
people laid off in a single week it
wouldn't be that surprising if we think
we kind of through the worst of it we
end a lockdown and then actually been
finished that's it even worse as global
lock downs ease the economy faces the
greatest challenge in living memory
here's what you need to know
[Music]
in China factories are up and running
classrooms are full restaurants are open
but the economy has not returned to
normal in fact its operating at around
90% of usual levels and as lockdowns e's
elsewhere this 90% economy could be what
the rest of the world has to look
forward to regardless of how countries
have dealt with the pandemic it's
becoming clear that once businesses have
to operate with social distancing in
place the economy can be expected to
shrink by about 10 percent whether
that's in South Korea America or Sweden
but the missing 10% will mean life will
feel far from normal in China large
chunks of everyday life are missing
having collapsed in January consumer
footfall has recovered to about half its
previous levels hotel occupancy is still
down by around 50% and 75% fewer people
are flying
what's mainly in the missing 10% is
stuff that it's hard to do if you're
trying to social visit so things like
restaurants at hotels theaters cinemas
and crucially it's also the way in which
people tend to have fun there's a world
where you work and then as soon as the
day is over you immediately get back to
your house as fast as possible this dip
in so-called fun spending will continue
even after lockdowns are relaxed
in Sweden most people were never asked
to stay at home during the pandemic but
Swedish spending patterns over the past
few months have mirrored those in
neighboring Denmark which has been under
lockdown daily restaurant turnover fell
by 70 percent last month as uncertainty
over the economy and fear of infection
meant fewer Swedes ate out and while
overall Danish spending fell by 29
percent during lockdown Swedes cut their
spending by almost as much what the
evidence suggests now is that actually
it's people's own voluntary decisions
about how they behave with shaping
economies actually more than what the
government is telling people to do the
lockdown itself is not really
influencing behavior that much the true
economic impact of imposing lockdowns
will take time to emerge in China it was
several months after the lockdown began
to be lifted before bankruptcy numbers
started to rise it wouldn't be that
surprising if we think we kind of
through the worst of it we end the
lockdown and then actually bail in film
starts to get even worse than we had
expected
for the past few months the global
economy has been propped up by
unprecedented levels of state aid in
Europe's five largest economies one in
five workers is currently in a special
scheme where the state pays their wages
the governor has deployed 750 billion
euros to sustain companies that's
unprecedented the government is going to
step in and help to pay people's wages
it's only as this support is gradually
withdrawn that the wider cost of covert
19 will become clear it will feel quite
sort of uncertain because you know no
one really knows how businesses and
households are going to be able to
survive weeks and months of of much
lower incomes it will impact all levels
of the economy let's take a look at one
scenario a small business owner runs a
chain of restaurants when the pandemic
hits he takes out a loan and furloughs
his staff he's not alone in March more
cash was handed out to UK businesses
than in any month since records began
after lockdown he reopened but business
is slow so he makes staff redundant and
closes a restaurant as he can't pay the
rent
this has already been happening in the
first quarter of the year the share of
commercial tenants who paid their rent
on time in Britain fell from ninety
percent to 60 percent with big firms
like Burger King admitting they couldn't
make rent on empty restaurants without
these rent payments his landlord can no
longer keep up with her mortgage and
ultimately her bank is left with debt
that cannot be repaid the problem with
all of these losses across the economy
is that someone eventually has to sort
of admit that they are going to bear
these losses and the color consequences
of that for business confidence and for
investment could be could be very
significant if you are concerned that
your customers or your tenants or
whoever is not going to actually be
paying the money they owe you then
making new investments is not just risky
it's actually completely impossible to
price because everything is so unstable
and so the risk of that is that things
like investment get cut back massively
and that will you know that will have
very large effects key economic factors
already indicate that the world is
facing a prolonged recession
already unemployment in America is at
its highest rate since the Great
Depression
but these losses will not be felt
equally to see how let's go back to our
restaurant owner the industry's hit
hardest by the clover 19 pandemic our
labor intensive and rely on an army of
low paid workers and it is these people
who are particularly likely to lose
their jobs in America you are already
twice as likely to be made redundant if
you're earning less than $20,000 a year
then $80,000 a year the kind of jobs
that won't exist at all or in much
reduced numbers will be the kind of jobs
that are typically done by people who
are paid less john started on by women
and jobs that are done by I think
minorities more commonly so that's jobs
and things like pleasure hospitality
retail trade and that kind of thing so I
think you could expect an employment to
be really concentrated in certain groups
and these economic changes will shape
the political agenda in the post
lockdown world you can imagine a
situation where it becomes kind of
common sensical that the essential
workers who've kept the economy going
you can imagine a push towards trying to
improve their standard of living and
standard of work on the other hand you
could imagine a situation where
countries kind of closed it on
themselves and say you know we don't
want to move boats because immigrants
bringing disease and we want to make
sure that we have capacity to build
vaccines for our citizens for no one
else it's too soon to know which way the
political tide will turn and each
country's response will be different but
one certainty is that the longer we all
have to wait for a vaccine to be
developed and distributed or effective
treatment found the more pronounced the
effects of the 90% economy will be
my name is Callan Williams I'm senior
economics writer at the Economist if you
want to read more about the economic
consequences of the corona virus
pandemic then click the link opposite